hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cluster truck now
the last time you saw me play this it
was on a livestream which meant that you
got to see the unbridled unfettered
friendly from unfriend you lated
Katherine put up a definition of
untranslated rage against the developers
and admittedly it might have been unfair
so I'm gonna play this again and I'm
gonna try to play some of the custom
maps that they have available and they
have a whole lot and a whole lot cuz
people love this game but I'm gonna play
for you guys but don't expect me to be
any happier about it I'm probably still
gonna be royally pissed off but I don't
have any Maps cooked what why did I
assume that I would have map floated up
here I didn't even download anything I'm
not ready for this episode to start I'm
an idiot
wipeout Anson done seek force a son
Mario that looks like a boob I'm gonna
get that one ah
medieval matters I that's enough that's
enough okay look did they log no I got
restored to time don't I have ski hey it
worked okay so we're just gonna go by
likes and go from there alright
everybody ready
I like the boob one is actually highly
rated here we go what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] em all on I don't know if I'm
allowed to touch that I am oh oh that's
good [ __ ] a hand
ha-hoo-ha oh that's cool oh that's
actually cool Oh
whoa whoa hey I made it oh god [ __ ] up
god damn it huh
and it is I like titties
okay hey that's like I'm trying dude I'm
trying Oh drunk [ __ ] don't ask me how I
failed on that last one I have no idea
uh I have no idea yeah okay I did it
Oh boink okay bull ball aah oh god it's
so dangerous
uh-huh OOP oh come on hell yeah
now we're getting it oh now we're
getting it oh now we're really getting
it
Oh shitty tits ah I can make it back
like a grippy rubber rubber boo - my dad
I'm gonna go get the NAS probably
cheating Ryan's broad cheating I'm gonna
get the - that seemed that seems
legitimate I could - let's see that
seems good enough I mean if I had the
grappling hook that would definitely be
cheating and I a new cheater huh let me
try to do it legitimately and I'll just
do this oh god oh god oh god ah I can
get through all of this in one go I know
I can poop I just got it yes No how are
you able to do that no one's gonna be
able to do that that's impossible
ha ha buddy ah that's jiggly is she okay
oh I see it there's platforms in between
um how am I gonna be able to do that ah
ah not like that oh boy oh boy yeah [ __ ]
you I'm sorry
holy [ __ ] okay up and over
okay up oh my just Molson I'm just
supposed to jump and not not run forward
on that one in and and then another
thing that back yep
yes okay so I'm just Wow
[Music]
okay so I just got a gum and go forward
Oh YUM oh okay here comes a big guns
Mario [ __ ] Mario really oh my god
this is this Mario oh oh oh my ride oh
holy [ __ ]
ah what the [ __ ] ow damn dead yeah hope
I can't [ __ ] how Richter [ __ ] yeah
okay yeah hey Cassie Mario Mario this
reminds me of the first person Mario
that uh rocket jump did like back in the
day hey get back in the day up [ __ ] dear
oh it got caught oh I got dead go what
what why didn't you be alright oh maybe
it would be better to have the double
jump in this one why I'm I get the
double jump cuz Mario can double jump
right yeah ho ki aho why o hawai he aho
he ah'd he aho yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] okay
why it doesn't make it a goddamn sense I
don't get what this material is but it's
not it's not authorized truck matera
[ __ ] hi
come on how did I do it before I wasn't
such an idiot before I bet caboose key
okay
ha okay ha okay ha ha [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you
do okay ah ha ha [ __ ] goddamn it
okay I need to just go around that one
huh barbar [ __ ] if I almost had that
hey grab rah I can't go back I need to
look back that's what I need to do why
aren't I looking back ah ah ah ah yes ah
[ __ ] no where is it oh god okay alright
okay this is fine oh [ __ ]
what you lied to me you lied to me I'm
going back to the - man Devon ow
now where I'm supposed to be ah Oh why
goombahs have pointy dicks here go [ __ ]
yo oh yes yes yes yes okay what why was
was was this okay all right okay all
right got this hot [ __ ] gay [ __ ] you I
was gay okay god damn it stop that stop
that that's so weird because the problem
is when you are touching it you jump
you're like sticky to it so you don't
really jump okay I got to make this ah
oh yes okay so ah there's gonna be a
[ __ ] grab the coin I don't know if I
want to do that okay oh boy
I can't move to the right left enough oh
[ __ ] you
so I gotta grab the coin but I'm just
gonna wait until point huh yeah no okay
it's got a what wait push me off and
pushed me off
why yes okay whoa oh boy oh boy oh boy
hey look odd since it does it
disappearing so I just gotta immediately
jump Oh
so jump watch it doesn't help if I miss
it
[ __ ]
ah yes I get to play the boob level I
want to play that one now doesn't seem
to be loading pretty sure it broke okay
vomiting the ball pit is a level that
doesn't lewd I'm out play truck canons
cuz it sounds cool and alright okay oh
now we're gonna work yeah I did it so
what am I supposed to do and where are
the truck cannons and why did I hear a
truck cannon no oh that's not good Oh No
hey okay well I am [ __ ] aren't I ah I
can't how do I uh oh I can't do that
where's hello truck ah
boink why [ __ ] I rolled off the wheels I
think it said something about use
levitate but I don't think I have
levitate as a power
what is levitate lets the player
levitate oh well I guess that's it then
we're gonna do that one cuz apparently
that's what we need to make truck canons
work okay this time I'm not gonna be
caught off guard
boink purp am boink mmm
boink mmm ah I wish I'd love a tape
before levitate is awesome
okay I'm missing my ride holy [ __ ] hit
me ride somebody hit me
god damn it not like that I'm gonna go
backwards where I'm a par well I I mean
I mean technically I'm still going just
in the wrong direction we're sure sir
where are we going all right then I
guess we're riding off into the sunset
so it's good a place to end it is anyway
I'll see where this journey takes me but
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of this and
if you want more down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]